yo what's up baby girl this is a Eric
calling from Denver Colorado and I
probably got a that bad boy the diamond
audio show and I got a question for him
sorry I'm talking kind of faster than
doing some cocaine yeah my question is
was the craziest street fight he's ever
seen or been a part of and I feel I
think I know yours is when you got out
of when you ran into the head button
champ and it didn't go your way but uh
Co take care and then a whole try and
stop doing that okay man I haven't been
part of a street fight and to answer
that question haven't part of a street
fighting I don't know how long yeah and
I don't want to do that I don't want to
that's all I'm off the clock yeah yeah
did you ever see Anita have you ever
seen some real wild ones dude last one
that I could think of that I've been in
mm-hmm was one Mardi Gras down in
Lafayette Louisiana I was at my
brother's house and it was like a street
party you know the holster everybody's
out on the street and my wife was
leaning over a fence talking to somebody
and then guys from next door came over
and like bent over her back while she
was bending over and put his hand on her
stomach and like started talking in her
ear and then I bro you just saw red huh
yeah I ripped him off I had a buddy of
mine who fights he started dropping this
other guy's people left and right dude I
mean dude 100% every shot that landed
everybody fell he shot a hundred percent
from the field that man then I started
punching this guy and then he he had a
lot more friends than we did and my
brother is not a fighter so he didn't
run he didn't run out of the house to
come fight but it was just like people
were fighting every and yeah and I ended
up getting my back up against a car cuz
they were jumping yeah I was like yeah
and I got hit with a bunch of uppercuts
it was crazy man Mardi Gras Mardi Gras
things water gots fun now yeah yeah
anything can happen at Mardi Gras dude
yeah I love that dude my buddy uh some
guys slept in his truck all night one
year my something a portal at one time
in New Orleans
I don't have a place yeah Oh like a
porta potti yeah I mean this seat was
down but yeah that's like the
ritz-carlton compared to where some
people sleep out there it gets a little
deep out there you know it's crazy as my
sister can't even read but what does it
have to do with us right now hope you
enjoyed that video and you can watch
another and you can watch this one you
can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one guess what